all right hello everybody today i'm
going to be talking about
grace in the ending and uh
i think in order to do so i might step
back in time a little bit and talk about
the concept of
grace grace of course a theological
concept
i'm not a theologian but i think it's
kind of augustine was the big dude
behind this
and the kind of idea was some people
have god's favor and some people don't
those that do are called the elect and
those that don't
well they're out of luck and um
you know where it's interesting is when
i look back on my own chess career
before computers
there was a sense of like when you
played someone really strong that they
had some kind of
gift that they could see something or be
part of something
that was spiritual or higher
and now with computers i find the
discussion has moved on to
this other uh dichotomy between
those that have some kind of gift which
you could call genetics or whatever you
want
else might want to call it or that it's
learned and there's
you know a big fight kind of a dogmatic
fight between the two sides
um and as a chess coach or
as a fan as a player as well i'm not too
interested in the fight of like genetics
versus
like learned behavior i'll just say as a
fan especially i've witnessed
what i will call grace and that is
and you get this especially in decisions
where somebody's mind kind of pierces
through
the fuzziness and lack of clarity in the
position in a remarkable way
and uh as a fan that's just a remarkable
thing to perceive and i think
all of us at some level have felt
like they had some kind of experience
like that on the board
as well and that's one of the things
that draws people
back into the game again and again
okay so what i'd like to do is just take
a couple examples to try to kind of
flesh out
what might be meant by this idea of
grace
okay so the first one you might have
seen before
uh i think it is a classic example
of how to play the
rook ending well and
um this is
capablanca tardika were back in the day
1924
and the first time i think anyone sees
this position
they're kind of blown away and
let me just show you what a kappa
blanket is why to move if you want of
course you can pause and try to
think about it yourself so uh king g3
x glam and really when you think about
it it's like well
if you don't do king g3 you're kind of
in trouble
what else are you going to do and the
king needs to come up
to help shepherd this pawn in
but also maybe to create some threats
against the black king
another feature of the position that's
very important
is that in general in the rook ending
connected past pawns
are just horrendously valuable so if we
win the pawn on f5 which our king might
well do
in a lot of variations then that's a
good thing
so let me just this we could spend
honestly the whole
lecture on this decision here
but i want to go through it kind of
quickly just to give the sense that oh
right
capablanca had a sense that this was
coming and i'm going to try to blow your
minds a little bit more after we go
through
a lot of these key moves we're
threatening mate
and we're again threatening mate and now
we have a completely
winning ending mostly because
our king is so much better right
and then right the game goes on and this
was a position that was analyzed a lot
by alekhine and reddy and all these
other guys back in the day because it
seemed mind-blowing
and i think it's a great example i think
if you wanted to
ask you know try to teach somebody what
rook end games are
this is a good position to start with
because it really emphasizes
the power and necessity of coordinating
the rook
and the king and that the king
is there to escort to shepherd the
white pawns and i don't want to go into
all the details i just wanted to
share with you that not only did
capoblanca play king g3 here
but where it gets even more interesting
in my mind is you go back
and let's talk about say
this beautiful move g5 and it fixes
g6 and invites
knight e3 to f5
so you ask yourself well wait a second i
mean most players would not allow this
it would just
seem like why are we letting the knight
in
and aren't we giving up our beautiful
bishop for the night
all this stuff and so when you see think
about it
this move g5 you said yourself right
cappa blanca had seen this move
king g3 coming up so that
you know it's hard to visualize the
transformation of the position
and then in order to play that move g5
we're playing king g3 you have to see
that and you have to understand
that it's winning and i think hubble
block is the first one
where people start talking in odd tones
about the guy's ability
to really capture
the essence of a plan kind of like
without thinking too much
about it you know i'm sure there's
obviously some thought just to come up
with that is pretty amazing
but to you know have a mind that's able
to pierce
through like i said the uh
a lot of the details maybe another key
and fun variation
is if you go this way we have to find
king h5
so that we're threatening king g6
and if you take well now again the king
is going to shepherd the pawn down
okay let's move on to
a second cup of blanca example
this one is also very famous from this
precise position
and again another great example of what
the uh rook and pawn uh
end game is striving for uh
you know there's a lot of times when you
look at rook end game books or end game
books they're teaching you algorithms
you know how to do x you know x y and z
in a specific
scenario and that's definitely important
but uh
more interesting to me and actually more
practically useful
is just the notion that your king and
your rook have to be
active and this game as well as the last
one really
emphasized what that principle
was all about so let's imagine
well i've imagined let me show you what
he did you can pause it if you want to
think about it of course
and he played capoblanca played f5
takes king f4
and look we're getting our rook in at
our king's taking the pawn
and the h pawn is loose it's
actually all over
and our king's coming in
game over now again this position you'll
find in a lot of
ending books i think
of f5 and it's a great example a great
pedagogical example
of how do you play the the rook and king
ending
but again like the last example i kind
of want to blow your mind here for a
second
and that we can go back and
white has had a nice little edge for
most of the game
and all of us regardless of your level
struggle in positions like this to find
uh plants you know to find plans that
work and
most of us won't be able against strong
opposition to really break anybody down
but watch what he does okay rook h2 so
now we're threatening the e pawn
okay and now there's a question of like
well what does black do
he can't take the rook on g5 he can't
move the queen because of like a rook
takes h5
i5 thing um
and the um
king well we're going to see what's
going to happen with the king
now maybe black if he had been savvy
could have thought about rook e8 but
there's going to be a long road after
that
so what i'm going to try to say is he's
seeing that there's the zuke swan
here that's involving the f5
break so let's check it out snip
you can't take with the pawn you gotta
trade queens
and then there it is we have our
position right there it is there's our
position
so again grace grace in the ending makes
it look
so makes it as if it were easy you know
to be playing these moves
okay one reason i came up on this
idea of talking about grace is over at
the chess dojo we've been holding a
wednesday book club
talking about gill fans latest
book called technical decision making in
chess it doesn't sound very sexy
but it is um been
really interesting to see
really how you play positions say like
this
and um
one thing i talked about in our the
lecture last week was the idea of
inertia in the ending
and one of the features of seeing
inertia we all have inertia
in our plans that is we have a kind of
sense of where things are going and it's
oftentimes hard to pull back
from those plans when they're wrong but
it's more possible to see those
as i discussed in last week's lecture by
those i mean
plans more possible to see plans in the
ending
because it's possible to
more possible to make a whole series of
moves and especially that's the case in
pawn endings
you can in my experience you will be
able to think
at the highest level of depth in pawn
endings more than any other kind of
position in chess in general you know
you can go
10 moves leap 10 20 moves deep and then
confound that question
the dumb party question of like how many
moves deep can you think
you know because usually you can't think
hardly any moves
deep at all but in a pawn in the game
you can often
do so this spawn end game
i don't think you could uh do it when
you're playing and gelfand admits as
much
and what's interesting to me about this
is he
comes to this position and says a4 i
must be winning
now i can imagine coming to this
position and saying
uh yeah yeah okay i'm i'm not going to
lose and i feel pretty good about it but
to say i'm winning that's another
interesting thing because there's so
much
that can happen between uh this position
and
actually winning the game um
so i'm going to show what happened a
little bit i won't go into all the
variations but then i'm going to take
you back to where i think the decision
was made
and in principle i think we can say
white black has one problem and that is
that
our two queenside pawns are holding back
these pawns and yes black can break with
b5
but if he does so his pawns will be
split and weak okay so let's look king
c6
king c3 this is in fact a high level gm
move
i think a lot of people would be afraid
of king d5
and might have played king d3 so that
they could play e4
but for girl fans this is obviously
winning now i want to say i i stress
that because to me it wasn't necessarily
obvious and i had to calculate this
whole long variation here
where the only really clean variation i
came up with was
f3 x glam where if you play f4 then
that's going to enable
g5 and the race is going to be a little
bit tight but f3 he's going to have to
come take this guy and then get in the
way of the f-bomb and we're going to win
the race
so again grace i was very hard
for him i don't i'm i'm not convinced he
even calculated he just said king d5 e4
and white is winning okay b5
snip snip e4
g5 h5 and now
definitely a mistake by
uh gelfant and he played f4
which is kind of insane because it
allows this
which black didn't play this is hari
krishna playing black in 2014.
in any case it's still winning for white
but it's going to take a little bit of
work in the game this was done
and you get to see the point pretty
clearly here
where the pawn is going to run the e
pawn is going to run
black has to go back to fetch it we go
and
strip up the black pawns
okay so where it gets interesting though
get more interesting let's put it that
way
as we go back a little bit
and white's been nursing an advantage
for a couple moves now he's got that
extra pawn and there's all kinds of
things he can do
but when he plays queen h5
he sees the end game he sees a4
so let's take a look queen d7 what else
you gonna do
rookie six snip snip snip
now many people would take on b6 without
thinking
uh and maybe it's mildly promising to
take on b6
but there will be counter play right
there will be counter play here
so instead king c2
and now there's just this big threat of
rookie 7
and if rook g5 we can jam the rook with
moves like g4 and f4
so then king c7 has to happen
and there's our end game you know and
so you come you're imagine you're over
here
and you feel pretty good about this
position
and it turns out queen e6 might win more
directly but you know
you want to make it as clean as possible
and you have your reservations about
queen e6
so you see the pawn ending here
and you say to yourself right a4 is
going to win not because i've calculated
it i haven't you know
not sure about the calculation i just
know it's going to win
i to me that's a great example of grace
okay let me share another example
all right so this game i was in st louis
last year and this was from the 2019
senior u.s championship with the
veterans alexander golden
against alex jormelinski both rook
and game experts and uh
alexander's up a pawn and they're both
alexander's golden's up a pawn
and yermo just played rook a2
doing the standard thing where he's
going to get behind
the pawn and
well the um
general rule of thumb that i like is
that you can if you when you ask
yourself is a position winning
you can say well uh it's winning if
there are two weaknesses
and here we can say that black has a
weakness in that he's down a pawn
but that in itself isn't it isn't
usually the end of the world we need
something else
we need some other weakness
okay now and black doesn't really have
another weakness
right so just by that measure it what we
have here is not enough
okay um
another very basic rook end game
um rule is that
there's three positions of the rook
the best is to be beside the behind the
pawn
the next the second best is to be
uh on the side of the pawn and the third
best is to be
in front of the pawn and um
whether then that's whether you are the
defender or the attacker
in all those cases you want to be either
be behind
second best on the side and third best
in front
and why don't you want to be in front
well one of the key reasons is let's
imagine the rook is on b8
and you start pushing this pawn you
you lose scope of the rook with every
time you push and then it's going to be
really hard to actually move that rook
once you get there
so i think uh a lot of players here
would play rook to something like rook
c5
rook c7
now i have to plug in my computer before
it dies
they play rook c5 rook c7 and
you know you would just have that one
advantage
and here alex thought for a while and
played what was in his mind a winning
plan and i got to interview him after
the game
and i was amazed at his level of
certainty
and it really reminds me of the gelfand
game as well
and he played rook c8
so it's anti-intuitive
in that you know the rule of don't put
your rook in front of the passport
because that's what's going to happen
here
all right so an amazing thing
about this intuition
is that he's already imagining
something and he's saying that it will
come to pass
now let me bring up an analysis board
and share with you
what uh i'm talking about here
so if we look at this position
as a known thing and you can see that
rook on a8 is terrible
if you like we can even shift it to b8
doesn't matter same thing
and let's start pushing this pawn
my pawns are pretty magical they can
move more than one square
but white can't do anything else anyway
and we push it to h6
and then you ask yourself well how do
you make progress here
you can't there's nothing to do there's
absolutely nothing to do
and uh you know let's say you go harass
this guy
and then you go you know you come here
i'm just going to be able to check you
to death
i'm going to check you to death and go
back to rook b1 and you got nothing
and the situation would be exactly the
same
if the pawn were here nothing doing
so uh once i've actually i was uh yermo
who's playing
uh black in this game he made the joke
that we could give white
all kinds of extra pawns and it still
wouldn't matter
it would still be a draw okay
so um the key idea
is that white needs some other pawn
the g pawn isn't going to do it but the
f pawn
will and um let's say we get here and
the king is here
well now it's winning because king f7
is rook h8 let's just show that
rook h8 excuse me
sometimes rook h8 rook h7
or b7 rook h7 and of course
if he takes on f6
we have rook fa so let's call that the
skeleton
of the idea that golden's going to
execute let's return there
so what golden is saying is that
he will get a past pawn that is not a g
pawn and not an h pawn
i.e one of these pawns will make it
and uh to me that was real
interesting because when i start like
thinking about a position like this
i just i'm like well the guy can do all
kind of feels like he could do all kinds
of things
and um yeah
but you get inside his mind a little bit
and you start saying
okay i guess i can see it and say it's
totally gone
it's absolutely gone here which is yeah
a moment of grace and
this one definitely comes from you know
a knowledge a deep knowledge of that
skeleton position
and just then thinking about this pawn
structure and saying
right and away now i think yurimo could
have made it more difficult
for golden by not doing e5 because e5
will i think help white
make the pass pawn in any case i did
play around with this position
quite a bit and i wasn't able to come
to any way for black to solve it
so let me just share the end of this
game
and what is irmo doing irmo is hiding
the king
with the thought that the um
the uh rook won't be able to check him
kind of like hanging out on g7 but this
time he's going to hang out on
h5
always go back there's no rush and b7
rook b4 but now f3
now f3 and we will get that point
that that pass pawn and here it goes
boom
e4 f2 what is it
i don't know what else he's going to do
he can't take the pawn and e5
coming up the board is coming fast and
furious
root b3 king e2 and your mo resign
so a really delicious game i felt
and an example of grace so
i could do many there's of course many
many more examples
but the thing that i a couple things i
just want to end on here
is that
there's many moments that i guess i
would call spiritual when you experience
them as a player
where you feel like you've understood
something that goes
through the madness of chess
and a lot of the times you know i think
most chess players
speak for myself when they're playing a
position there's a kind of an opacity
to it you know we're just happy if we
see a little bit of something
there's an opacity and there's very rare
moments where you feel like you can see
through the position
and that's what i mean by grace and it's
sometimes possible in the middle game in
the opening but i think
especially in the ending it can be very
beautiful and powerful
because it will be not just a couple
moves it will often be
quite a long series of moves that you
are going to need to execute
to get to your desired end
okay i hope you enjoyed this theological
discussion and uh yeah we'll be back
here on the st
louis channel real soon bye bye